So if I could have any element  I wanted for Christmas,
I think I'd choose Hassium. Because I know nothing about it.
I make the video about it and I'd really like to see it,
to see if I was right.
What does it look like? What does it feel like?
What colour is it? But I don't think I'll get it, at least this Christmas.
Well, as a girl I would say Carbon, because we all know
that diamonds are the girl's best friends. -Terbium. it's got a good name.
Helium because it makes your voice very high. -Helium, fantastic element. Very light, very fun.
It's got to be Oxygen, isn't it? Yeah. -How come?
Well, to sustain life basically.
I will go for Aluminium to cover my turkey. -I do have an answer for that
but I don't want to put out for public consumption. -Really? -Yeah.
It has to be Mercury,  just so I could play with it.
-I'll will say Mercury.  Mercury is the coolest element.
Play with little footballs on the desk.  -That'll be Platinum, I could flog it.
make an absolute fortune, that.
-It would be Platinum because it's the most expensive element.
Probably Neodymium because it can be blue, red or green which are all Christmassy colors,
depends on how concentrated the solution is, so you could modify it that way.
Rubidium. -How come? -It's explosive.
What I'd really love for Christmas is a nice big chunk of Caesium
that I could go and drop in to perhaps a small bottle of water.
And in true fashion,  I don't have to wait till Christmas
because I am not going to be here. This is what I got this morning.
It's my Christmas present. It's 5 grams of the finest Caesium.
Nicely bottled up in this little old ampoule as you can see. Got my grubby mitts on it.
Warmed it up, lovely liquid metal. So what we are going to do with this  metal
in the new year? I wonder.
I think it's Oxygen because I am doing research, so...
I want Oxygen for the Christmas gift.
Dysprosium, just got a good name.
Well, I love Boron,
so Boron is a really nice element to have. But if I was going for a transition metal,
I really like Manganese.  It's not particularly colored,
but it's got some really cool chemistry.
Sodium -Sorry? Sodium. -How come?
It's the first one I thought of.
Xenon, because it's nice and stable, relaxed.
Nitrogen and because I do more work using Nitrogen,
it does not react with other elements,   especially it gets rid of Oxygen.
Ok, Silver because it's beautiful. -Gosh, that's a good one.
I guess I've got to go with Gold just because of what it is.
Doesn't oxidize, doesn't discolor, it lasts forever, there we go.
Magnesium because we share initials.
What's your name? -Mike Greenwood.
This is the first Christmas that we've celebrated with our periodic table of the videos
and we've been really thrilled by the number of people that have contacted us,
have made comments, have made suggestions and I hope in 2009
we all make even more suggestions and that we can bring you
some really quite exciting chemistry.
Oh... sorry
. . . . . . . . . . . .
Captions by www.SubPLY.com